economic freedom is a really interesting
topic and most people i think uh they
talk about the assets they talk about
the technology but they kind of lose the
plot as to what the potential impact on
a global stage can be
what is it about the economic freedom
that you think kind of caught your
attention or really kind of drew you to
that specific idea of that measurement
yeah well you know i had experienced
this firsthand um in a couple different
ways so
one was that i had spent a year living
in buenos aires argentina i just kind of
went there after college to try to
figure out what i want to do with my
life and sort of live abroad for a bit
while i was working on a different
startup
and one of the things i saw in that
culture was just how broken um the
financial system was it was really
holding people back not only with
inflation which was kind of eroding the
wealth especially of the poorest people
in society
um but it was also making it hard to
like you know get a mortgage to buy a
house like businesses were all uh
struggling to collect and send payments
um it kind of created this atmosphere of
despair and and resignation i would say
in the culture like people just weren't
optimistic or wanting to try
try cool things to go help people
because they felt like i could all be
gone tomorrow it could all be taken away
from me so it was this like really
insidious problem in that society
and other ways i saw it was for instance
i was i was an early employee at airbnb
we were helping move money to people in
190 countries uh people renting out
their homes and um collecting payments
from people who wanted to stay there and
i just sort of had a front row seat into
how how broken the global financial
system was it was this huge barrier to
innovation it had high fees delays um
you know oftentimes it was kind of felt
like almost like corrupt or just opaque
in terms of
how it would work and it was like
it just never made sense to me growing
up with the internet where we had this
global system
you know you could send an email or a
whatsapp message it would arrive
instantly anywhere in the world for free
why weren't payments like that it's like
why was why was every single country
creating its own proprietary system that
could be corrupted or manipulated or
just have you know incompatibilities so
that's why i got excited about it and i
felt like economic freedom was this huge
unlock basically it was it was almost
like solving a meta problem because
you know you could argue things like the
industrial revolution and um some of
these things that have happened
historically
just by giving people the ability to
you know if you do something good for
the world you can capture some of the
upside that's a very simple but a very
powerful idea and arguably it's almost
sufficient to get
a huge amount of innovation and progress
happening in society so i'm very excited
about you know how do you how do you get
better more progress happening in
society how do you bet get more
technology innovation and property
rights and economic freedom are kind of
a core foundation of that so i felt like
this might be one of those rare moments
in history where a small group of people
could take this brilliant technology
innovation bitcoin
and with the
proliferation of smartphones and the
internet actually inject economic
freedom and property rights and good
financial infrastructure into all these
countries all over the world
um really even just from one company
doing that and that just i couldn't stop
thinking about it for
you know a year and so eventually i was
like alright i gotta try creating some
kind of a prototype and that led to the
origin of coinbase
uh you made a good bet because uh that
seems to be what is occurring as as
we're watching this all uh play out here
um i should say before we have a
conversation about the public company
and uh and some of the regulatory stuff
i've got equity exposure to coinbase
obviously you're a shareholder in the
business and uh nothing here is
financial advice but in terms of uh
coinbase you've built a business that is
today worth tens of billions of dollars
and recently took the company public any
lessons learned from that process of
going public any things that have
surprised you or or downsides that maybe
you didn't expect as well
um yeah you know so actually i wasn't
sure that i wanted to be a public
company ceo when i first started
coinbase because
you know i'm like an engineer product
person by background
i felt i'd read all these stories about
how once you take a company public it's
like there's kind of activist
shareholders and you have to spend you
know i talked to some public company
ceos actually and when i was trying to
figure all this out and they were some
of them told me
they spent 30 40 percent of their time
just talking with public market
investors and to me i felt like you know
this might be something that just slows
us down and how we're going to create
great products but i realized over time
that you know there's many different
ways to go public and you can actually
create this in a way that's very
beneficial to the company so
just to give you a couple examples that
are
like very positive reasons why why to do
it and why part of why we did it
you know one of them is that um it's a
huge legitimizing force for not only
your own company but for the industry uh
so for instance once we became a public
company a whole bunch of fortune 500
companies started you know being more
comfortable working with us on
especially on the institutional side of
our business and on the developer side
but it's um
i didn't realize and appreciate this
until we went public like the the level
of
legitimacy that it actually applies to
the company now on top of that it gives
a whole bunch of liquidity to the early
investors and the employees i think over
a million
sorry over a thousand millionaires were
created at coinbase when we went public
which was an incredible statistic so
that was just hugely emotional and
life-changing for so many people and it
turned out to be for me as well
and then it gives us now that our stock
has this kind of liquidity to it it's
given us a liquid currency to go out and
do more international expansion
and things like that it also by the way
it's much easier to raise money as a
public company um you know we've
recently raised um like two billion
dollars in debt and the whole thing took
about one week um i actually didn't have
to go to a single meeting for that um
although our cfo did a whole bunch of
meetings so my hat goes out my hat's off
to her
but um yeah there's some definite
advantages of being a public company
i've so far i've been really enjoying it
i'm planning to
keep doing it for a long long time and
i'll give a plug to the direct listing
we did a direct listing
instead of a traditional ipo
i thought it was i thought it was great
i think we got um
we got better deal terms we didn't feel
this kind of
pressure to underprice the stock for
insiders we wanted it to be a totally
fair thing we went out so anybody on day
one could uh retail institutions you
know anybody could bid and buy at any
time and it was a fair market for
everybody um i think the direct listing
was a very positive thing so i'd
recommend that to other founders
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]
you